Heys that leia
it kind of looks like her from Return of
the Jedi I don't know is that the crash
Star Destroyer from first teaser you
guys stop I'm trying to watch the
trailer who are you
depends who you ask there's a lot of fan
theories floating around but you can
back order a tiny version of my droid
for 150 bucks nothing will stand in our
way
fix but you started I don't like Sam its
course
raaah
get some
those stories about what happened it's
true all of it midi-chlorians
without the midi-chlorians life could
not exist
George are you support odds are pigs the
special editions they're real but forget
all that some new nerds directing now
and this looks awesome
hey remember those things TIE fighters
are still cool right who's that guy he
looks bad I bet us giving you goosebumps
right about now we could show you two
hours for monkey washing a cab and you'd
still go see this movie
the prequels then gnawing at you just
let them go where's Luke do you turn on
the dark side or something
weisstein the trailer what do you want
to do give away the whole movie hey guys
don't forget the trailers for The
Phantom Menace also we're kind of cool
don't ruin this for me be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers can I
wash my Winky in your kitchen sinky
Chewie were home
waffles are just pancakes with ABS time
is dead and meaning has no meaning do
you ride your teeny tiny bicicleta to
school